this morning in our series i on earth we
have a first look at the future of
electric cars in america
transportation accounts for almost one
third of our greenhouse gas emissions
that are blamed for global warming part
of president biden's infrastructure bill
would help
people buy greener electric cars which
as you know are more expensive
general motors plans to stop making gas
powered cars by
2035. first on cbs this morning ben
tracy got rare access to the facilities
the gm says will power its electric
future
on the assembly line at this gm plant
outside detroit
there are two things auto workers like
mark owens
will never see again internal combustion
engines
and gas tanks how different is this
completely different
i never thought i would see in all
electric vehicles where we didn't have
any gas tanks in it
this is where gm is making the chevy
bolt the company's only mass-market
fully electric vehicle
but that's about to change it's not so
much if
it's just how fast mark royce is
president of general motors
he says electric cars will no longer be
a novelty for the rich
gm is now betting big on batteries
planning to launch
30 new electric vehicles across a wide
range of price points
in the next five years do you feel in
any way like you're kind of building a
new company inside
the old company i do it's the biggest
thing that the industry has seen in a
long long time
gm is rebuilding this massive 4.5
million square foot plant in michigan
now called factory zero as in
zero emissions the name of the street
out front
also got juiced so the robots look ready
to go
ours were the first network tv cameras
led inside to see what plant manager jim
quick
says is the factory of the future this
body shop
when complete will be the biggest body
shop in all of general motors
the biggest one you got the biggest one
we've got
factory zero will soon produce an
electric version of the once notorious
gas guzzling hummer
and this summer gm will launch this a
larger version of the bolt
called an euv you made a lot of
headlines when you announced that you
won an all e
feed fleet by 2035 right when you look
at the actual statement and said your
aspiration
is to eliminate tail pipe emissions
that's right there's some wiggle room in
there
there's a little bit of wiggle room in
there but the aspiration to do that
is really going to be based on the
consumer and how well we solve some of
the problems
that people perceive around electric
vehicles i do think most americans look
at electric cars and say that's not
something i can afford too expensive
yeah
that's because batteries have made up
about 70 percent of an electric
vehicle's cost
they are now getting cheaper gm is
building and testing them
in-house to further drive down costs
automakers are also counting on the
federal government
president biden's infrastructure plan
calls for 500
000 new ev charging stations across the
country by 2030
motor trend editor alisa priddle says
automakers will soon offer consumers
far more ev options the reason that
people don't buy evs right now
is they don't want some funny little pod
that doesn't do what they need
for their lifestyle or their family
right now of the 250 million vehicles on
american roads
less than one percent are electric last
year evs accounted for just two percent
of all u.s auto sales
almost all of those were sold by tesla
which is now worth more than gm
ford and toyota combined the tailpipe is
an endangered species because states
such as california and massachusetts
and countries including japan the uk and
the entire european union
are soon going to ban the sale of
gas-powered vehicles
to combat climate change
ford just announced it will go all
electric in europe by
thirty it's already selling a battery
powered mustang in the us
and next year it will electrify the best
selling vehicle in the country
the ford f-150 pickup truck you really
cannot afford as an automaker
to not have a full portfolio of
electrified vehicles
really in the next five years or you are
going to be left behind
did you know that norway sells way more
electric cars per capita than the us
gm is playing the patriotism card
telling americans in its ads
there's no way norway should be king of
the eevee road
we're going to crush those losers and
mark roy says he expects some automakers
won't survive the transition that desire
to win
is very deep i would say anybody that is
making electric vehicles now or in the
future
is high motivation internally for us to
win
a fight for the future that is
electrifying
motor city for cbs this morning ben
tracy
detroit well you can see mark roy's
determination there he is
yeah it's an inflection point in the in
in the history of the automobile
the tail pipe is an endangered species
that's quite a statement
don't you remember back in the day when
you heard about someone with an electric
car you did a little eye roll like oh
god either they're elitist or they're a
hippie or they're just you know
la-dee-da but that is certainly
yeah no in the old days it's not you're
afraid to get on the freeway with you
know yes
yes everyone's bigger than you faster
than you stronger than you
that's changed an electric hummer sounds
pretty impossible electric hummer i
never thought i'd hear that